i don't like first dates for the guy
spends a lot of money
and that's because i feel like if he's
spending a lot of money he expects
something right and i don't want to i
don't want to feel like i owe you yeah
and i'm like
so we can just do coffee and i've been
on coffee dates and got something
[Music]
i'm just saying yeah but there's a
difference like
some guys get entitled yeah no they they
get entitled to the point they get mad
yeah i just spent all this money on you
what the hell are you doing yeah right
and and then i just prefer to avoid that
situation like i'd rather split than
just feel like i have like have to do
something i don't want to do yeah i only
do that splitting thing
in relationships
yeah i hear that yes that's the only
time i do it because yeah because i was
in a relationship for like 10 years yeah
yeah yeah listen we there was things
that we split those things that we
didn't like but that whole if you're
gonna do something for me i'm with you
and you're with me so it's like it's
that's the only time i do like that
splitting thing that's true you know
relationship that's the only time i do i
heard that okay i got one last question
then we're gonna wrap up the show how
long is too long to wait
for a girl like to sleep with her like
how long would you date a girl until
you're just like it actually depends on
the goato if you really liked her this
is a girl you really really like because
i think i think i asked you guys you
guys wouldn't wait until you were
married for a girl right no no no no
okay can't even have sex she doesn't
even know what she's doing okay but at
some point but is she like because
usually they say sex but i don't think
they caught
or all different
they think they think orals completely
different from sex you can suck my dick
for six months even after that
um sorry i've got no
like none of that okay so oh nothing
yeah not like well like nothing not even
like kissing and playing no no you could
do that like
um nothing sexual nothing sexual kissing
but no no
because because there's a line and it's
interesting because you know the church
i think this is kind of going back to
the church
because they'll tell girls that have had
sex before to wait right and sometimes
that can be bad advice because guys are
like why would i wait you got a kid
i can visually see that you've done this
before
like why would i wait
like
you screwed the whole football team at
penn
state a year ago you were like doing all
kinds of things yeah yeah so
my question i always ask this to guys
because you hear such conflicting advice
right because you'll hear
guys say oh she doesn't sleep you with
you in three days be gone like like move
on to the next girl but then you hear
guys say
that
um it doesn't matter if they like them
but i'm like i don't think most guys
will wait till they're married
so it's just
i think i think
i think there has to be
sexual progression
so like if the first couple of dates
we don't kiss but let's say the third
date we do kiss but it's a tamed one the
next day maybe it's a bit
more yeah i don't know maybe no tongues
you know it's like a record or something
i think if i'm for me personally if i'm
seeing sexual progression
then i'm like okay we're just going at
her pace
i'll be honest though like if i don't
even get a kiss by a third date no i'm
out
because that because by that point she
knows that she's attracted to me on food
like yeah i know if you attract me or
not if you're if you are attracted to me
i believe most girls today they would at
least kiss you by the third date
but if they haven't then they're just
not attracted to you in which case what
am i doing well i'm but i'm i'm talking
sex i'm not talking kissing
how long are you going to wait until sex
yeah
and like you're talking as in so you're
not talking sex you mean sexual like
anything sexual yeah like anything
sexual oh my gosh oral or or sex like
either way
we want to hear you say it
three four months coming now
like for the right let's be real let's
be real yeah you're right okay so
after i'm just going to say after about
three months
are we saying like one day a week let's
say on average well you're going on one
day a week yeah but you're talking on
the phone every day at night
baby i love you oh my gosh
if we're going on a date a week
and we're talking all the time
two months
right
two months i think because at that point
like you you're just not that into me
i would think you're just not there yeah
but then they go you think she's getting
it from somewhere else
either raw you're not yeah yeah you're
not into me enough but some people some
people might actually be just that long
you know i'm saying that they might just
be that's very true you know what i
think girls were told three months
weren't they
apparently there's
[Music]
i mean but listen i'm not going to wait
that long
i won't lie
at this point in my life being 40 years
old i think they're older
what the [ __ ] am i waiting for i got it
i think age makes a difference yes i
think the older people get the more
they're like let's just get to it i'll
go somewhere else my dad like don't
worry about it
here's my question
can you be
intimate with other people
while you're dating this person or this
is the only person because then that
extension
intimacy because there's having sex then
there's making love that's true so like
the [ __ ] you've got so you're saying the
bodies while you're dating this woman
you're having sex elsewhere
but are you just having so you're right
because you're getting your sexuality i
said i said extension
what do you think comes first the
relationship or sex
what do you mean like like exclusivity
or sex in your experience if if you're
dating without content
yeah because because now people yeah
that's what i was you think sex comes
first nowadays sex comes before yeah
exclusively the thing is if you're
dating sorry if you're dating with like
intention
i think
the relationship should come first
before the sex yeah yeah yeah if you're
dating with intent if you're if you're
intending i won't be married yeah if i
want to marry this woman yeah we're in a
relationship with a boyfriend and
girlfriend now get your clothes off
i think yeah quick question don't you
guys think that it has something to do
with what you are doing with yourself at
the time also because
you will be doing something
to say you have a career path and you're
like you're an actor yeah yeah you're
busy bro yeah
shanice hasn't got like you can't talk
to chinese every day because you've got
stuff to do but i mean you can
any man who likes a woman will find time
in his day to talk to you no no i was
going to get to that i was going to get
to that yeah so you shanice you you
ain't got time to talk to her but when
you when you have free time mm-hmm
you're gonna talk to sunis yeah like
because it's like bro like and that's
all you wanna that's the only person you
wanna speak to that's true so like
you you
these girls that you're you're
not these girls or chinese
you're gonna you're gonna want to spend
more time with her
than
anything else when you have your free
time you're absolutely right so like
that goes into into like
how you choose i guess and
that's a big part
when i said earlier when i kind of went
on a bit of a mad one when i came out i
was just like it's not sustainable
because it starts to affect my work
where it's just like anyone who i spend
my free time with i i have to like who
they are as a person right
so you're absolutely right why is that
say again why is that
why do i have to like them as a person
yeah because i'm giving them my time
right and energy
and i think
exactly and because it's your time and
energy you realize
when it's these these
like
doesn't that force you to kind of be
more serious about just life in general
and because and how you spend your time
because it's like bro if i if i spend my
time here this was not this didn't
progress me to anywhere it didn't make
me better well i would
what i would argue is that i don't spend
time with someone um
based on
what the future could be i base i spend
time with them because i was waiting
with them in the present
right yeah yeah does that mean so it's
like the most
like men versus women thing to say
that is not how we think
like he's gonna be great soon
yeah that's what will it be i could make
him great i wouldn't be like oh i'm with
you today because of what we could be
tomorrow yeah yeah because tomorrow may
never come
with you today because today is what but
then but don't you when you get if you
get into a relationship ain't you
planning
for
two three years from now
so i think i think if you get into a
serious relationship
still um i think if i think if you get
into a relationship or maybe at least
for me then yeah you think about those
things
i think i don't plan logistically
because like i'm not looking to get
married and settle down right now
so
that's not i don't think about that if
i'm like maybe when i'm in my mid-30s
and i start seeing someone seriously and
i'm like oh okay well actually yeah how
do you know sorry 27. okay you got 10.
so